und noch mal kurz an den kommentar
verfasst von eben wenn dir das video
gestern hochgeladen haben gestern abend
dicker wie schnell soll ich nun das
klauen
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja weil ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt gut eigentlich war
heute kein video angesetzt weil ich
absolut klausurphase bin für meine
scheiß uni ich bin so froh wenn ich
meinen studenten dauert zwar noch ein
bisschen aber irgendwann habe auch ich
ist hoffentlich mal geschafft trotzdem
bin ich gerade ziemlich aktiver münster
da gibt es jeden tag werden foto von mir
und auch eine story weil ich das so
nebenher macht jack das gern mal ab na
ja auf jeden fall war deswegen heute
kein video angesetzt ich wollte ein paar
tage pause machen bis ich dann jetzt in
den letzten zwei drei stunden einige
kommentare gelesen habe ich gedacht was
ist denn jetzt wieder passiert oder habe
ich damals irgendwie ein video übersehen
und praktisch das gleiche gemacht wie
schon jemand vor mir kommt ja manchmal
vor
aber dann wisst ihr wo ich sage immer
das ist nicht meine idee ist ob dann
habe ich realisiert
ok mittelfränkischer die haben
wahrscheinlich irgendwas durcheinander
geworfen und zwar reden wir von diesem
video hier fünfmal in einer stunde beim
selben lieferservice bestellt es gibt
ärger
das habe ich vor zwei monaten
hochgeladen vor zweieinhalb monaten von
trink- brauch- geklaut da denke ich mir
wirklich junge widum können kinder
heutzutage sehen das ist einfach nur
traurig für die jetzt aber überhaupt
nicht wissen was los ist
die lieben frank france haben gestern
das video veröffentlicht fünfmal
hintereinander beim selben lieferservice
bestellen eskaliert oder es gibt ärger
eigentlich hattet ihr auch es gibt ärger
reinschreiben können ich meine das macht
es auch nicht verbessert und noch mal
kurz an den kommentar verfasst davon
eben wenn ihr das video gestern
hochgeladen haben gestern abend die ja
wie schnell soll ich denn das cloud also
da muss ich wirklich sagen so schnell
bin ich auch nicht länger ich habe mir
dann aber gedacht so ein video style
gemacht machen wollten eine reaktion
darauf ich schaue mir das mal an und ich
bin gespannt was mich erwartet aber ich
habe auch mal ein bisschen rum geguckt
also so ein video hat wirklich noch
niemand auch nicht im amerikanischen
raum oder so gemacht und der titel ist
ja auch komplett gleich er hätte er
wenigstens meinetwegen sechs mal
bestellen können dann hätte man ja noch
eine kleine abwanderung gehabt oder eben
was anderes vorgestellt meinetwegen im
supermarkt fünf mal das gleiche gekauft
oder so aber nein na ja gut so kreativ
muss man auch erstmal sein
okay wir fangen an
[Musik]
also geht erst mal direkt im junge junge
ich habe leider vom stativ diesen
adapter den man unten braucht vergessen
deswegen steht da nur so drauf so ok
also es geht schon mal sehr aggressiv
los da liegt natürlich auch schon mal
die vermutung nahe okay ich habe gleich
so ein paar punkte wenn man ganz klar
erkennen kann auf das release oder nicht
weil ich habe das ja selber gemacht denn
wir versuchen so oft wie möglich
versucht anzurufen und dementsprechend
zu provozieren mal gucken wie wir haben
das gerätetyp bis sie nicht mehr kommen
oder so ist keine haare bis sonst was
passiert wir gucken mal wie oft das geld
ein kleines experiment aber wir tun ja
eigentlich regulär bezahlen und wo sind
die grenzen
das ist heute und sie stellen das online
über eine app bezahlt auch dafür jetzt
schon mal los
man bestellt online über eine app ich
gehe mal davon aus sie haben das mit
lieferando gemacht weil lieferando ist
halt das einzige was ist gerade noch in
deutschland gibt soweit ich weiß die
lippen kommt noch dazu
aber mehr fällt mir gar nicht mehr ein
diamant alles aufgekauft und lieferant
ist ein extrem großes system und wenn du
jetzt bei einer pizzeria was bestellt
kommt da irgendwer von den tausenden
lieferando fahrern in deiner stadt hin
und hole das ab und bringt das studiert
okay gut vielleicht nicht 1000 aber es
gibt auf jeden fall mehrere das heißt
die chance dass ein typ 5 ball kommt ist
extrem gering das war bei mir auch nicht
so ich glaube da kam zweimal ich weiß
nicht mehr ganz genau und am ende hatten
wir nur die situation dass der chef ihm
wohl gesagt habe dass ich die ganze zeit
bestellt habe und jetzt mal sagen sollte
hier reicht auch mal aber er weiß auch
nicht so krass aber okay also zum
fünfmal es ist schon wieder ein anderer
eltern
es werden ja nach anhalten werden oder
müssen jetzt erleben
jedes mal sogar trinkend und trotzdem
drin
ich will meine rolle ist immer die ganze
zeit com wer die ganze ist für ihren
rasanten andere mit der kamera ganz okay
aber alles klar
so jetzt hat geklingelt
er kommt erst stellung dürfte so
ablaufen
[Musik]
nur eine piste warte mal kurz also jeder
von euch hat ja schon mal pizza bestellt
wahrscheinlich und wenn ich pizza
bestellen dann kommt der typ auch mal
hier hin
ich weiß jetzt nicht das ist jetzt noch
kein hundertprozentiger beweis
aber die haben ja eigentlich mal so eine
tasche dabei wo das ganze essen drin ist
damit es warm bleiben es sei denn die
wohnung einer kleinstadt und erst mit
auto unterwegs sei es das system noch
mal anders
ich kann das selber weil meine eltern
unserer kleinstadt wohnt da kriegt man
auch die person in der großstadt kriegst
du dir halt in seiner tasche damit
sachlichkeit wird nur eine pizza
bestellen erst als bradl können wir
jetzt essen so erste bestellung ist
vorbei jetzt bestellt wir warten mal ein
bisschen komisch dass sie gar nicht
zeigen was sie da bestellen oder wo dies
bestellen
aber was man sah gewusst der typ sieht
schon aus weil sowieso ein typischer
lieferant finde ich da haben sie sich
auf jeden fall mehr gegeben falls es
gefällt ist ich will jetzt natürlich
auch nicht zu 100 prozent sagen dass es
fähig ist aber für mich liegt es sehr
nahe gerade wenn man sagt man bestellt
über irgendeine app keine kleine
pizzeria hat irgendein ab
[Musik]
warte mal kurz eine pizza und burger für
79 90 das hat er doch gerade gesagt oder
also das ist ja der günstigste
lieferservice den ich je gesehen habe
790 findet förder und eine pizza von ok
vielleicht ist das der günstiger waren
die schlecker haben dann noch mal was
ich an kohle haben oder so das jahr zu
franken vor der zero und genau an
getränken bürger einfach derart wichtig
und wir warten wir auf die piraten die
köpfe
[Musik]
ich habe alles auf diesen authentischen
fußtritt müssen wenn sie noch mal
ankommen
ich bin aber so sei jetzt muss ich
erstmal gegen das geländer treten
[Musik]
brauchte er warte mal kurz das macht für
mich absolut keinen sinn
er sagt dem gerade ich muss den tank
selber bezahlen ich krieg das nicht
bezahlen aber du kriegst auch die
arbeitszeit bezahlt dann ist es doch
total scheiß egal ob du jetzt zudem
fährst oder zulegen im anderen kunden
das macht absolut keinen sinn also
sondern dem ausland habe ich echt selten
gehört
ich muss sogar sagen dass der typ der
den lieferanten spielt das echt verdammt
gut mit auch wenn diese aussage nicht
überhaupt keinen sinn gemacht hat weil
sie sozusagen die macht ja keinen sinn
macht es trotzdem ganz gut
einfach so irgendwo zwei maschinen will
doch einfach so ganz trocken
das verstehe ich halt nicht also man
kann ja wirklich wenn man so etwas macht
dann zeigt man noch mal cool video oder
wo man das bestellt oder nicht oder wie
das aussieht was man dargestellt das ist
einfach youtuber logik man will ja immer
alles zu seinen zuschauern zeigen so das
ist eigentlich ganz natürlich warum wir
das nicht machen finde ich ein bisschen
komisch jetzt kommt indirekt ja ich bin
ein gläubiger haben bis 11
[Musik]
hallo
hey das ist also um jetzt mal die kirche
im dorf zu lassen sagen wir mal so ich
würde auf 10.000 euro darauf hätten kein
lieferant geht somit kunden um denn er
tritt als essen in die wohnung
ich meine das sind ja einfach nur kunden
und natürlich wenn man jetzt viermal
hintereinander zum gleichen bestellt
wird dann sagt man mal so jung was los
und hier macht das bild jetzt reicht's
auch mal so dass haben ich weiß gar
nicht mehr was ja bei mir gesagt hat
könnt ihr euch ja gerne auch mal
angucken er war auch ein bisschen sauer
so aber so sauer auf keinen fall sollen
wir noch immer noch einmal musik kommt
keine sein wollte gab es wird ein
fünftes mal dann endet das ganze weil er
zu krank wird er richtig wie die tiere
haben eine sache habe ich noch ich gucke
mir gerade viermal so diese tüte anderen
weil wenn in der tüte wirklich essen
drin ist was ja so sagen wir mal einen
halben kilo wiegt oder ja vielleicht ja
sagen wir mal ein halbes kilo dann zieht
dieses plastik der tüte ja eigentlich
ein bisschen runter und wenn da halt was
sehr leichtes drin ist bleibt die tüte
so relativ in der form versteht was ich
meine und das sieht wenn man mal hier
schaut so aus als wird das überhaupt
nicht so nach unten ziehen wirklich eine
sehr mysteriöse sache einmal geht noch
okay jetzt bestellen die abkürzen ich
bin mal gespannt wie teuer diese acht
pizzen sind dürften ja eigentlich nicht
über 40 eur q2 wenn die pizza oder
schöne 790 kostet dann kostet ihr eine
pizza nicht mehr als fünf euro
[Musik]
das macht der geräte
1 2 3 4 5 und 5
was macht also das mich wirklich ich
persönlich bin mir zu 100 prozent sicher
auch wenn es gar nicht mal so schlecht
war an manchen schwer haben ihnen video
was auf jeden fall fällig jetzt bin ich
mir sicher an manchen stellen ist es gut
gefällt an manchen stellen überhaupt
nicht weiß wie diese am ende macht für
mich null sinn warum er plötzlich wieder
zurück sind und dagegen schlägt und die
haben ja gesagt sie haben absitzen
bestellt ich habe da sechs gezielt
wahrscheinlich hatten die nur insgesamt
sechs pappkartons hatte es auch ein
bisschen dumm
mein name ist da ja gesperrt
stimmt habe ich vergessen schreibt mir
sehr gerne mal in die kommentare was ihr
dazu sagt so aber für mich ist es
einfach nur sehr sehr traurig und ticker
ich finde das so krass dass 51.000
menschen das so richtig abfeiern und
dann daumen nach oben geben klar ich
kann auch sagen in gewisser weise kann
man als youtube adipös auch nur
bewundern ich meine sie ziehen ihr ding
durch und geben den verkauf alles andere
aber ich finde es halt auch so uncool
wenn mein video einfach geklaut wird und
wirklich eins zu eins geklaut das ist ja
wie gesagt fünf mal beim selben
lieferservice eskalation was willst du
machen das was von mir ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen und wir sehen uns
übermorgen wieder dann bin ich erstmal
durch haut rein